hello my name is Dave Ruiz Feld and I'm
a customer engineer with Google cloud in
today's session we're going to talk
about modern content delivery at scale
our agenda for today's session is a
brief introduction about CD ends in
general and what is cloud CDN and then
we're going to talk a little bit about
some of the new features that have
recently been released on cloud CDN
we're also going to talk about some
adjunct capabilities that support cloud
CDN and really help provide additional
functionality for your configurations
and lastly we're going to talk a little
bit about some upcoming platform
enhancements that we're making to both
cloud CDN that I think you'll be really
interested in seeing so we're jumping
right in what is cloud CDN so before we
kind of go there let's talk a little bit
about what a content delivery network is
in general a content delivery network is
a series of web servers that are
designed to deliver content close to end
users generally speaking when customers
look to use a content delivery network
they're really looking to get access to
one of five key benefits some
performance benefit by serving content
close to end users global reach being
able to expand beyond their origin
infrastructure and having the CDN give a
point of presence high availability
ensuring that there's no single point of
failure in the delivery chain
scalability both in terms of vertical
and horizontal scaling for planned and
unplanned event activity but also from a
security standpoint both in terms of
secure content delivery but also in
terms of denial of service and security
mitigation capabilities so cloud CDN is
Google's content delivery network that
has been designed for accelerating web
and video content the cloud CDN platform
has been built to support Google's
exacting needs what I mean by that is
the cloud CDN platform that you use on
Google cloud is the same platform that
Google uses for delivering search
results for delivering Gmail results so
you know that this is a highly
performant and
we scalable content delivery network
platform specifically as it relates to
cloud CDN
there are various performance
capabilities that we embed into cloud
CDN things for example like the
industry-leading time to first byte
these are a lot of the technical kind of
nuances that we baked into the cloud CDN
platform to ensure fast response time
fast throughput time and a lot of that
comes around from Google innovation
things like speedy that manifests itself
as HTTP 2 we also look at things like
quick and how that is quickly morphing
into the new HTTP 3 protocol but you
also can look at new standards in in
pacing for example like the bbr
functionality that you can find in cloud
CDN that was first developed at Google
global reach the cloud CDN platform is
consists of over a hundred and forty
different edge locations around the
world in 35 different countries this
ensures that you can have a point of
preference anywhere around the globe
where your end-users are located from a
high availability standpoint Google
backs up our our cloud CDN platform with
an SOA a ninety nine point nine five
percent availability SLA to ensure that
you always have your content delivered
and it's always going to be available on
cloud CDN in terms of scalability the
cloud CDN platform is a multi terabit
per second content delivery platform
this is an active platform delivering
tera bits of data on a daily basis today
this is not a new platform but this is
simply the commercial use of Google's
existing content delivery network
platform and lastly from a security
standpoint cloud CDN supports both PCI
and HIPAA based workloads you also have
the ability to customize TLS handshakes
whether it's in terms of specific ciders
or specific TLS protocols that you want
to use one of the highlights of cloud
CDN is the network
so many of you have been familiar with
the Google data centers within cloud
within the cloud program but added to
that are the edge CDN nodes or
distributed around the globe some of
those locations are within Google Cloud
data centers where you're doing compute
today but we're also in other satellite
locations to extend the reach of the
platform interconnecting all of those
nodes our Google controlled fiber so
unlike some other competitors in the
marketplace cloud CDN interconnects all
edge nodes with Google controlled fiber
so when there is a cache miss on the
edge server you are routed your request
back to the Google origin location
across Google controlled fiber and this
is a key differentiator of cloud CDN now
in our next segment that we're going to
discuss today I want to highlight some
recent releases of the cloud CDN
platform specifically there are kind of
two areas of focus that we really want
to kind of segment content through
there's performance characteristics and
their feature enhancements that we've
recently released the first feature we
want to talk about is TLS 1.3 this was
recently released in April of this year
where the entire fleet has been upgraded
to support TLS 1.3 one of the main
benefits of TLS 1.3 is it is faster it's
about 40% faster over TLS 1.2 and that
really translates itself in time to
first byte right by by reducing the
number of round trips a client needs to
make with the server in order to
establish an SSL connection the faster
we can start delivering the payload the
content that the end user really cares
about one of the other enhancements
that's made to TLS 1.3 is that it's
removed some of the obsolete insecure
ciphers that have been found in previous
versions of TLS 1.1 and 1.2
approximately 80% plus of end-users can
support TLS 1.3
today so in order to take advantage of
this there's nothing that the end user
needs to do their browsers already
supporting cloud CDN just makes this
available as a protocol option for the
end user to communicate with the cloud
CDN server the next feature we want to
talk about is custom origins prior to
the release of custom origins the only
way for content to be fulfilled on cloud
CDN is through infrastructure or through
content that's actually hosted and
domiciled on Google Cloud whether that
be a storage instance or a compute
instance with the introduction of custom
origins you now can attach third-party
origins that are not part of your Google
Cloud tenon in order to have that be
delivered by cloud CDN so this now gives
you the ability to extend the life of
your existing origin infrastructure and
still support cloud CDN this also can be
useful as part of a migration strategy
as you move content into Google Cloud
you can use cloud CDN as a bridge to
kind of optic eight your origin
infrastructure migrate your
infrastructure into Google Cloud and
then change the pointer of the back end
so this becomes a huge enabler for not
only cloud CDN but also as part of a
content my dream migration strategy the
other thing to kind of point out here as
a differentiator is with the custom
origins we support not only HTTP HTTP
1.1 but we also support HTTP 2 so while
the end user client to the cloud CDN
edge can support HTTP 2 many other
content delivery providers downgrade the
protocol from the edge talking back to
an origin with custom origins you have
the ability to maintain the HTTP
protocol from edge all the way to the
origin so you can take advantage of
head-of-line blocking and multiplexing
capabilities of the HTTP
you protocol from an integration
perspective something to be cognizant of
is with these third-party origins they
still must be publicly available so you
can't use an RFC 1918 private IP address
for this it still must be a publicly
available IP address subsequently you
also that web server also needs to be an
HTTP oriented web server whether it's
HTTP or HTTPS in terms of its protocol
exposure so you can't use any like a UDP
style protocol there the next feature I
want to highlight that was recently
enhanced to the cloud CDN platform is
along the lines of access control now
prior to the release of sign cookies we
always could support query strings as a
way to mitigate content the content
access and to help the hype and help
prevent the hyper distribution of
content we've now introduced the ability
to support sign cookies so not only can
you use query strings or sign cookies
you can actually use them together as a
way to provide more comprehensive
content protection strategy generally
speaking though if you think of how the
access control works today there are
three more the three core elements to be
cognizant of there's epoch time this is
the time of the expiration of the URI
asset there's the key by default Google
can support up to three keys
simultaneously and you can rotate those
keys at will through your car your cloud
CDN configuration and lastly there's the
hashed value that you use to kind of
create that that's kind of secured token
value based on the key and the URI path
that you want to incorporate as part of
the security check all three things need
to be present as part of your access
control to prevent the hyper
distribution of the URL now one of the
things that's unique about cloud CDN is
that there are other ansel Ettore
functions within Google cloud that
actively support the cloud CDN service
so if you think about how cloud CDN
comes to life it leans on these other
capabilities of the wider portfolio to
enhance the offering in this portion of
our discussion I want to kind of
highlight a couple of those new features
that were recently released that provide
additional functionality to the cloud
CDN user experience the first feature we
want to talk about is redirects and
rewrites in this particular function is
an extension of the Gluba of the Google
global load balancer today we now have
the ability to perform redirects and URL
modifications prior to this you had to
do any sort of rewrites or URL
modifications on your origin
infrastructure with this new release the
Google global load balancer has the
ability to dynamically do the rewrites
our redirections we see this quite often
in terms of use cases for things like
HTTP to HTTPS modifications we also see
this as part of a URL shortener strategy
where you might have a short friendly
URI path for marketing purposes but
behind the scenes you we want to explode
the URL to actually point to the actual
origin destination the next feature we
want to talk about as a highlight and
extension to cloud CDN is on logging
more specifically there are two edge
cases that we want to highlight here
number one is the edge cache status
prior to this release the cloud CDN
platform never exposed the behavior of
the edge cache whether or not we served
it from cache or we had to fetch that
from the origin with this latest
enhancement we now expose this
information to you in the log line so
you now have the ability to see whether
or not the actual edge cache served it
from its own stores or disk or if we had
to fetch it from the aura
this can be important in helping you
figure out your optimized content
offload strategy and so you can set
alerts you can set a monitoring against
these data attributes in the log line to
help improve your offload rates the
other enhancement that was recently
released inside the log lines is the
IATA code of the Google cloud CDN edge
server that did the delivery the IATA
code is kind of a three as a three
character code sometimes is referred to
as like the airport code of where that
Google Cloud CDN edge server actually
resides so the idea behind this is you
have some visibility as to how Google is
actually delivering your content to
end-users now mind you this is not the
actual destination of where the end user
is located this is merely the edge
server that was used to fulfill that
specific edge request the next feature I
want to highlight here is cloud armor
we've recently now enabled cloud armor
to work with the cloud CDN origin
infrastructure for those of you that are
not familiar with cloud armor cloud
armor is Google's in line security
offering for waffe and network layer
protection and this is designed to help
protect origin compute resources
specifically with within cloud armor you
it supports OS mod security rules but it
also supports IP whitelisting
blacklisting as well as country level IP
whitelisting blacklisted the benefit of
using both cloud armor ends and the CDN
platform together is it gives you
fantastic volumetric protection but it
also provides presentation layer
protection such that you can now protect
origin workloads and deflect requests
that have been detected by the security
rules or your IP or country list
blocking schema so
your origins don't need to deal with
those requests that you know that we
know are basically of malicious intent
the other benefit of working with cloud
armor and the cloud CDN platform
together is that the messaging for cloud
armor is directly embedded within Google
load balancer log lines so with both of
these solutions in place you have a
single source of truth where you have
visibility in terms of what is allowed
or denied and if we denied or allowed a
request you can see the policy rule from
cloud armor that specifically was being
enforced in order to affect that
specific log line request now we'd like
to turn into a little bit into the
second half of the year
what are we intending to bring to market
within cloud CDN the first feature I
want to highlight is flexible cache
control with inflexible cache control
there are three core capabilities that
fall under this umbrella
there's cache control there's header
manipulation and there's error handling
as we talk about cache control before
the flexible cache control release cache
control header values need to be
dictated by your origin web server and
many customers have complained that that
was not how they wanted to control the
cache setup with the flexible cache
control release the the cloud CDN
platform now will have the ability to
apply cache control rules on the CDN
platform itself this will help improve
the cache offload rates by you no longer
having to manipulate your origin web
server but it also simplifies the
workflow process where the CDN
automatically will apply the rules
rather than you having to be more
specific about your work and path and
header manipulation within your web
server configuration specifically from
an integration standpoint we will have
three
main setting options so we will still
maintain origin cache control values and
that still will be available to you but
we're going to add two new capabilities
for being able to serve cached objects
for static objects as well as the
ability to just simply cache everything
where in this case we will ignore
whatever decoration the origin is
supplying in terms of cache control
header values whether it's private
public etc and we'll just apply our own
TTL setting values based on your
configuration setting in the case we're
using cached static objects mode of
operation what we will do is we will
apply the cache control values that you
dictate in your CDN configuration based
on specific mind types and those mime
types are listed here on our slide the
third component or the second component
we want to talk about with inflexible
cache control is header manipulation and
within header manipulation there are a
couple of different use cases that will
be addressed with this release the first
one is the ability to add downstream
response headers to the end-user client
this is helpful for things like adding
course header values which can be
important for for streamed objects or
JavaScript objects that require
additional helper module like helper
directives to allow the browser to
leverage the particular object that is
being delivered the next capability
within the header manipulation bucket is
the ability to bypass a cache on a
header request and this can be helpful
to distinguish between an authorized and
an unauthorized user or it can be used
to determine things like a logged in or
a logged in user so for example you
might want to have a cached page
experience for for unauthenticated users
and in the case where you have a more
personalized experience and the user
actually is authenticated you might want
to bypass the cache and go directly to
the origin for a more customized
experience delivered up from the origin
itself
the third use case under the header
manipulation is the ability to restrict
the methods that are being used so by
default Google is going to allow all the
met all different method types to get
funneled into your origin web server
with this new capability out of the
flexible cache control we now have the
ability to be more prescriptive in terms
of what feature mod mod method types
that we want to allow into the origin
the benefit here is that this will allow
you to tighten up your security policy
so for example if your website doesn't
accept post requests then we can
specifically deny post requests on the
CDN edge rather than funneling those
requests all the way back to the origin
where potentially it could be right for
vulnerability or exploitation the other
part of this when we talk about things
like adding course headers it helps
enrich the client request experience so
that we can take advantage of
capabilities that are native inside the
browser such as cores capabilities the
third extension of the flexible cache
control is error handling prior to the
release of flexible cache control and
the error handling module the cloud CDN
platform would pass through whatever
error it was handed to it from the
origin and this kind of manifested
itself in reduced of site availability
we're making modifications to the way
that cloud CDN behaves to to enhance
your site availability the first
extension of that is with negative
caching so specifically if you advertise
certain HTTP status codes from your
origin we have the ability to actually
cache those requests to help buffer your
origin from these responses the second
extension specifically around error
handling is the ability to serve stale
content so by default when an end-user
request is made to the clouds
and edge we're going to make the
determination if we have that content
we'll serve it if we don't have that
content but we have the object sitting
in cash we're going to consult with the
origin for revalidation of that object
of whether or not we can continue to
serve that out of our cash in the event
that the origin isn't available we would
in the past serve up an error response
with this new capability we now have the
ability to serve that stale content
rather than serving up the error page so
this is going to again help increase
your website availability but it also
helps buffer your origin at times of
high load from an integration
perspective some helpful tips to kind of
kind of share with you so first off by
default Google will be turning on
serving of stale content by default the
the TTL default value is one day so in
the event where we have an object in our
edge cache and we can't revalidate it
with the origin the default posture will
be to serve out stale rather than
serving up an error message subsequently
the negative caching will be an opt-in
feature where it will be available to
you but you must elect to configure and
turn that behavior on in your
configuration set that negative caching
will not be enabled by default in our
next that our next level of enhancements
that I would like to discuss with you is
around platform enhancements and the
first feature we'll want to highlight is
resource coalescing with resource
coalescing this helps particularly with
things like live streaming when we have
lots of requests all looking for the
same object in the past each request
would be treated individually with
resource coalescing or sometimes called
request collapsing we have the ability
to have to fulfill that request from
multiple edge requests from a single
request and share out that
response to the edge server rather than
making lots of individual requests
this helps with content offload from the
origin and also helps with content
scaling for high-volume de vents the
next platform enhancement that I want to
talk to you about is TCP enhancements so
as part of our recurring kind of theme
of always improving our time to first
byte and also improving our throughput
response rates we are making
modifications to the way that cloud CDN
will interact with the end user client
all of this is invisible to the end-user
all of this is invisible to you from a
configuration standpoint it just
magically will get better specifically
on the TCP enhancements we're making
modifications to our throughput but
we're also making enhancements to our
pacing so today we're using pacing from
web that leverages bbr for example one
of the things that we're looking at
adding into the platform in the second
semester is looking at adding the bbr
version to again another another
advancement coming from Google the next
item that I want to talk to you about is
HTTP 3 so today we support quick it's
more specifically G quick and this can
be found already embedded and it's
already enabled on Chrome and and latest
Firefox browsers today and this is now
enabled on your platform that you can
enable and opt into in your cloud CDN
configuration but we're not stopping
there we are now going to be extending
the quic platform from G quick and we're
transforming that to I quick which is
now the new standard for the quic
protocol the I quick is kind of a
precursor of sorts to the HTTP 3
protocol and as we start to roll out I
quick and the HTTP 3 protocol to the
entire cloud CDN fleet cloud CDN
customers will automatically have the
ability to leverage the
new protocol the benefit of using the
HTTP 3 protocol is going to improve not
only your time to first byte but also
improve the client performance and
stability for end-user clients
particularly on unstable networks so in
summary the cloud CDN platform is making
a lot of investment in our platform not
only in terms of enhancing and adding
new features and functionality to the
cloud CDN platform but we're also
looking at extending our
industry-leading performance
characteristics and capabilities
likewise were also making additional
investments in cloud CDN to revamp the
user experience so it's going to become
easier and more enriching environment
for you to use cloud CDN without having
to go to multiple different screens and
with that I want to thank you for
attending my presentation today and I
welcome to see you on a future
presentation